Let's go all the way back to one of my
favorite years,
1985,
and talk about Russia today.
There's so much happening in the news
lately with this giant country,
but since we're all in election mode
here in the United States,
pretty much all the time,
most of the news about Russia is getting
completely lost and there's a bunch
going on.
First.
There's the ongoing war with Russia in
Syria,
which has become the deadliest conflict
since World War II.
It's estimated that over 400,000
people have died so far,
and sadly it seems that there's no light
at the end of the tunnel.
Then there's the rumors that wikileaks
is somehow working with the Russian
government to influence our election
right here.
This is become a big talking point in
democratic circles as wikileaks
continues to drop information about
Hillary Clinton,
emails and Clinton Foundation donors,
even Julian Assan,
Wiki leaks,
editor in chief is promising more
October surprises and clearly they're
not going to be aimed at helping hilary
or the Democrats on top of those issues.
There's a lot of other reasons to
believe that Vladimir Putin sees America
in retreat around the world and he's
looking to fill that void.
Russia is occupied Ukraine for two years
now and it's clear that Russia is making
moves throughout Syria without us
approval.
Sometimes indirect conflict with
American goals,
although it's completely unclear to me
what exactly those American goals are.
Only four years ago in America's last
presidential election,
Mitt Romney was widely mocked for
calling Russia without question our
number one geopolitical foe,
and yet now it seems that it's the
Democrats who are leaning more hawkish
on Russia just listened to hillary or
Tim Kaine and the debate so far,
the democratic nominees are much more
anti Russia then either trump or pence.
Is trump to close to Putin or does he
have other Russian business interests in
mind?
I guess that's possible too.
There could be a new cold war brewing,
but this time there may not be a rocky
Balboa verse.
Ivan Drago boxing match on Christmas Day
in Mascoutah help us work things out.
While I don't think there's any
legitimate reason that a direct conflict
with Russia is on the way,
I do think it's important that we start
talking about are deeply complex
relationship with Russia in an open and
honest way,
not just by demonizing and making fun of
Putin,
which don't get me wrong,
he makes it very easy to do,
but by really understanding what's going
on within Russia and the geopolitical
circumstances which have led us to where
we are now.
If we don't do a little homework now,
then we'll all be easily manipulated by
both politicians as well as by the media
that has their own goals in mind.
Boogie men are a lot less scary when you
know a little bit about them.
My guest this week is author and
columnist Cathy Young.
Kathy grew up in Russia until the age of
16 when she moved to the United States.
She's written for the New York Times,
The Washington Post,
the Wall Street Journal,
as well as my hometown newspaper.
She focuses on some of my favorite
topics,
including political correctness and free
speech,
and from what I've seen,
she equally calls out the bad elements
of both the regressive left and the alt
right.
She's also been an outspoken critic of
modern feminism and a defender of the
men's rights movement.
Those she sees some issues with that
movement as well.
I've you,
Cathy,
is one of the few people really trying
to take both sides to task and give both
sides a chance before forming her own
opinions all the while not being too
attached to a specific ideology,
not being locked into a specific
ideology and being intellectually
flexible is one of the most important
attributes you can have and one that I
consistently strive to have for myself.
The last few months had been interesting
as we've seen many never trump.
Republicans slowly fall in line to a
lesser degree.
We've seen it with the Bernie Bros who
seemed far less inclined to go all in
for Hillary.
The wider point here though,
is that everyone is making their own
calculations and decisions based on the
information around them.
The key,
no matter what you believe,
is to have access to new ideas and
concepts and to have conversations
that'll either enforce your beliefs or
change them for the better.
My guest this week is an author and
columnist who's written for the New York
Times and Wall Street Journal and is a
regular contributor to reason and my
hometown newspaper,
Newsday,
Cathy Young.
Welcome to the Rubin report and it's
great to be here.
I am very excited.
That was your hometown.
That is.
I am a long islander.
Born in Brooklyn.
Grew up in long island,
lived in New York City my whole life.
Now here I am in La.
You're a Jersey girl though,
right?
I am.
Well,
I am originally from Russia yet we're
going to get into that,
but I have been a jersey girl since
1981,
so it has actually been a while.
That sounds like a book right there.
From Jersey.
From Russia to Germany.
Russia to Jersey.
Well,
I did write a book called growing up in
Moscow,
which was my first book came out in 89
when I was fresh out of college.
So yeah.
Well,
that's exactly where I want to start.
So,
so,
well done.
Okay.
So in my direct message,
I talked a bit about Russia and I have a
sense that in the next month or so we're
going to be hearing a lot more about
Russia between what's going on in Syria,
people,
you know,
talking about the Wiki leaks stuff and
is there somehow a connection that they
want to take down?
Hillary does,
right?
Does trump have a business ties to
Russia?
All of this stuff.
So let's go back to your first 16 years.
What was it like growing up,
uh,
in Russia and uh,
if you don't want to give me your exact
age,
give me a rough estimate of the years
that he was born in 1965.
Okay.
You never,
you never know.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm fine with that.
Yeah.
All right.
So let's talk about it.
Talk about growing up in Russia.
So yeah,
I was growing up in the president of a
years and it was interesting because at
the time it really seemed like the,
that existed
at the time was really forever.
Um,
and it was funny because,
uh,
there was a book,
by Russian dissident named Andrea Mora,
called Willis Soviet Union existed until
1984 and he picked that day because of
Orwell,
of course.
And it's so bizarre because at the time,
uh,
I heard about this book,
you know,
my father was a kind of,
well,
both my parents were really kind of
closet dissidents and we had banned
literature on the house.
Um,
and what was bad,
what type of literature was actually
banned.
Oh,
anything that was critical of,
uh,
of the Soviet system social needs.
And of course the works of dissidents.
Um,
there were,
uh,
there is her,
we're not even really formally banned,
but kind of really frowned upon,
um,
from,
uh,
the early years of the Soviet regime,
like people who were executed for being
a sort of an opposition.
I'm war.
Well,
of course was done.
Uh,
I didn't actually get to read it until I
had left the Soviet Union.
And,
uh,
it's interesting because a number of
people who read or,
uh,
well,
in the,
it was called Samas dot,
you know,
these typewritten leaflets that were
kind of passed around from person to
person underground of people who read
world who read or,
and sort of smuggled in for an to a lot
of people in the Soviet Union really
were shocked to learn that orwell had
never actually been to the Soviet Union.
Some of them were sure that we're,
well,
like George Orwell must've been like the
pen name for our Russian emigre because
who else could have understood the
system so well?
Yeah,
he did.
Yeah.
And the sort of the,
the pressure of,
uh,
the pressure to conform to the dominant
ideology.
So anyway,
yes.
So,
uh,
Andre Amalric who picked that date
because of,
uh,
the book 1984,
of course.
And at the time when I first started
that it,
I didn't,
no one could really imagine that this
would sort of come true because it
actually doesn't exist that long passed
the 1984,
you know,
he was off by 70 years.
That's when I was growing up,
no one really could have imagined that
and I think that's kind of a useful
thing to keep in mind when we think of
today's events in the sense that,
you know,
we really have no idea whatsoever what
the world is going to look like in five,
six,
seven years.
Things are really unpredictable.
They really are.
And that's why I did the direct message
because I want people to have some
knowledge about some of this stuff.
So the second we start hearing about
this,
I know we're not all caught guard and
have no cancer,
but you know,
in terms of what it was like to grow up,
uh,
in,
in the Soviet Union.
And it's really difficult to answer on
one word because,
um,
you know,
it wasn't in many ways it was a complex
society.
It was not the same as,
it wasn't in Stalin era where,
you know,
it really was kind of back down the
height of the totalitarian.
Um,
when you know,
very little,
uh,
information or content as we would say
today,
was allowed to kind of seep in.
That was not thoroughly filtered through
the official ideology.
I'm like,
at the time,
for instance,
uh,
back in the thirties and,
you know,
even the,
even the fifties a dusty yefsky was bad.
Maybe not,
again,
not officially banned,
but very difficult to get and certainly
wasn't studied in schools and colleges.
Uh,
by the time that I was in a high school
in Russia,
we actually had a prime and punishment
on the curriculum.
Um,
and,
you know,
we,
the things that mentioned religion were
kind of allowed a,
anything that really was not very
overtly critical of the Soviet Union
was,
okay,
well Dr Chicago for instance,
but I did have the experience of um,
you know,
growing up in a situation where when I
was maybe seven or eight years old,
but I started going to school and I
started coming home and saying,
oh,
well,
we live in the best country in the world
because we have communism.
That was when my parents decided that
they kind of had to explain to me that,
you know,
not,
not really,
that is not really quick.
Can do some of those leaflets that were
going around the age of seven,
but they just kind of talked to me and
kind of gave me a little bit of an
explanation of what was what.
And uh,
um,
and I remember very well my mother
telling me,
you know,
he really,
you cannot tell anyone at school what we
talk about at home because otherwise you
will go to jail.
And I'm not even sure that they would
have because again,
at the time,
you know,
things were a little more flexible and
open that they used to be.
Um,
I actually know of a situation,
a friends of my parents that they are
sudden started talking in kindergarten
about how,
you know,
he,
his dad was saying that Lennon was
really not the greatest person who ever
lived.
And um,
and nothing.
But actually he has one of the teachers,
one of the kindergarten teachers called
that his mom and said and basically
said,
you know what?
I don't really care what you talk about
at home,
but you know,
please don't do it in front of the kid
because you don't know who else is going
to tell us.
And she was pretty a pretty enlightened
for the teacher.
But in this society there was a lot of
kind of flexibility under the radar,
so to speak.
But officially it was all very conform
as we had to at school.
We had to attend these mandatory
meetings where everyone had to kind of
repeat the slogans and,
you know,
uh,
sing the praises of the Soviet Union.
And this is actually one reason that a
lot of the stuff that was going on today
in American universities really
resonates with me because,
you know,
I've been saying to my mom,
my dad passed away two years ago
unfortunately.
But I've been saying to my mom,
you know,
this really feels like the Soviet Union
where they heard you.
And so these meetings where you have to
sit there and say all the right things
and it's not just that you're not
allowed to say,
you know,
things you're not allowed to say is that
it's not.
You have to say the things you're
supposed to say,
which is,
well,
as I'm listening,
I mean,
I absolutely see that through line.
I'm not saying because,
you know,
we're not,
no one gets hurt into the gulag,
you know,
their resident.
Because I mean,
again,
when I was growing up,
I did know that he could,
you know,
it wasn't very likely maybe,
but you could go to prison,
uh,
for um,
you know,
saying heretical things.
But you know,
we are kind of getting to the point in
many areas of society where you can lose
your job,
you know,
for,
for saying the wrong thing or
ideologically which in the Soviet Union,
the 19 seventies,
that actually losing your job was a much
more likely outcome though I'm going to
present.
Like,
unless you were actually like
politically active as a destination.
Right.
It's interesting because I find that I
used to give anonymous people on line
more crap for being anonymous,
right.
A lot of people would respond and so,
you know,
I don't want to lose my job right now.
I don't know that there's a lot of
instances of that in the United States,
but it's more about that chilling
effect,
which is sort of what you're talking
about existed all the time.
So your parents never went to jail,
but they don't really talk about this.
It's funny for all that.
So,
so 16 years old you moved here,
was it because you realized that there
was this great opportunity
when,
uh,
they started really saying a Soviet Jews
in the seventies.
And my dad had actually talked for
several years about I'm leaving.
Uh,
my mom was a little,
um,
more uncertain about it.
She had a job that she really loved.
She was teaching at one.
She's a music teacher and she actually
still teaches a,
but she was teaching at one of the top
music schools in Moscow.
Uh,
and uh,
you know,
she had students that she was very
attached to when she just really felt
it.
It was funny because she felt that she
would never find that kind of work in
the US and she actually ended up doing
pretty well,
I think.
Um,
so yeah,
but,
so she was a little hesitant and it was
also just sort of the general
uncertainty,
you know,
moving to a whole new country,
learning a new language.
And I went to a school that specializes
in English by the way.
So I started learning English when I was
about seven and it wasn't really at the
time with a view to going to America
eventually it was just because,
I mean,
it was a better school than most and it
was a,
I think because of English there was
also more exposure to materials that you
wouldn't normally see on a curriculum
and so on.
So,
uh,
you know,
for me it was really,
at least in terms of language,
it wasn't quite as intimidating.
Uh,
my parents really did have to kind of
start all over again.
So yeah,
if finally,
uh,
I think,
um,
my,
my parents both felt that things were
getting worst were the end of the
seventies.
Um,
and uh,
at the time,
again,
no one knew what was going to happen.
Yeah.
Um,
a lot of people thought that there was
going to be a kind of resurgence of
Stalinist type,
uh,
you know,
really harsh,
brutal dictatorship where you could go
to present and very easily for saying
the wrong thing.
Um,
and uh,
at that point you were,
you were allowed to just pick up and
leave.
Your parents were allowed to just,
okay,
we're leaving now.
Not just,
well,
no,
no.
It certainly wasn't that simple.
I mean,
you had to apply for permission to
leave.
Um,
it was,
uh,
it was not for any one of,
was basically limited to so good Jews
who were officially being allowed to
leave for like repatriation to Israel
and worth family reunification.
And they really like the Jews,
but they weren't letting the Jews leave.
Is that pretty much the antisemitism?
That was another thing.
The antisemitism was growing much more
noticeable.
It was getting to be very difficult for
a young Jewish people to get into
college.
Um,
you know,
we,
my parents personally,
new situations where,
you know,
kids who were extremely good students,
uh,
were basically blog bull during the
admission exams and,
and it was this completely closed system
where they didn't have to tell you like
where you had failed on the exams and
the,
it was really,
really easy to kind of kill you if,
if they wanted to,
especially since part of the infants
exam,
by the way was Marxism,
Leninism and quiz here you had to write
all these tuxes,
you know,
the plenary session of the Communist
Party in 1956 and then they can quiz you
on the stuff and,
you know,
and uh,
and it was really,
again,
if they wanted to failure,
it was just really easy to do that.
So,
um,
you know,
and I think that was a,
that was another reason that prompted my
parents to finally decide to leave.
But yeah,
we officially,
um,
we were emigrating to reunite with my
father,
his aunt and Israel.
And um,
and then what,
how it was the whole thing kind of
existed under Jackson Vanik.
It was kind of an arrangement where the
United States where,
you know,
Russia was where the Soviet Union at the
time was getting,
um,
kind of benefits and trade with the US
in exchange for allowing Soviet Jews to
leave.
Um,
and I think there were a few other
groups like pentecostal Christians who
were kind of a very persecuted sucked
who were also part of that,
but mainly it was Soviet Jews say.
Yeah,
once you,
once you actually left the Soviet Union,
then you got to Vienna as a way station
and then you've got a choice of did you
want to go to Israel or did you want to
go to the states?
So you told them or they were under the
impression you were going to Israel,
but then you went to the United States.
I think they kind of knew.
Yeah,
I think they knew what was going on
because I think at the time,
like by the time that we were leaving,
I think about 80 percent of the Soviet
Jews who were at a grading,
we're actually going to the United
States.
They didn't really care.
So what was it like you,
you sort of had the benefit of,
as you said,
speaking English at an early age and go
into A.
Yeah,
what was it like though to move to New
Jersey?
16 and,
and he actually wasn't.
My very first statement was Jackson
Heights,
Queens,
Queens.
Yeah.
And uh,
this is funny.
My,
I actually um,
worked uh,
for about six months before my parents
eventually found work in Jersey and that
was why we ended up moving.
Uh,
but um,
for a while I was the main breadwinner
because I was the person with English
and uh,
I had a job as a secretary with the boy
scouts of America,
New York chapter.
Uh,
yeah,
because I also,
I knew how to type and I knew how to
tighten Russian,
but I rented a,
a typewriter,
an English keyboard typewriter,
and it took me about a week to relearn
how to type in English and I'm like,
what was that like?
I mean,
you go from Russia and now you're the
breadwinner for your parents in this new
country learning a new job and all that.
I mean,
how did that feel?
Oh,
actually felt really exciting.
I,
yeah,
no,
no.
That whole period of my life was
actually quite exciting because,
um,
you know,
just the mirror experience of going
abroad,
you know,
and my father actually had traveled a
bit because he was a musician.
Uh,
he had traveled with the Moscow Symphony
Orchestra.
He was actually mainly,
he was a sound producer,
uh,
for,
for the radio,
but he was also a violinist and uh,
uh,
he did occasionally get the travel.
He was,
uh,
yeah,
he had some interesting experiences to.
He was actually in England in 1968 when
the Soviet Union invaded Czechoslovakia
and he would have defected for sure if
he doesn't have a family back home.
And my mom actually wasn't even sure
that he was coming back because when she
heard about the invasion,
she was like,
oh,
I got you.
He's going to the doctor.
Uh,
yeah,
no,
he bought.
But he,
uh,
I,
I think he was very,
very talented and uh,
I mean,
I don't think he was tempted to actually
do it because he knew that he had a
family back home.
But he did say,
you know,
that if it wasn't for that,
he probably would have made that
decision because it was just a,
um,
and you know,
they had the experience of uh,
uh,
you know,
being sort of booed by the woodlands of
London.
It was just,
it was really,
really trying for.
Yeah,
they didn't know we could go on and
being an immigrant.
But it was,
for me,
it was
really exciting because first of all,
it was this whole world of information
that had opened up to me.
Like,
you know,
reading
well and reading his paper
and,
and I remember I just the experience
and I actually still remember this,
I remember when,
when we came here,
you know,
I opened,
um,
I think it was the New York Post and
this was,
this was shortly before Reagan was
elected.
So you know,
I opened the New York Post and I see
this
really mean cartoon of Jimmy Carter and
I was like,
this is just the president and here was
this cartoon.
It basically did some as a complainant.
I mean I love that.
I love obviously frame so much of what
you write about and,
and that was just an amazing and that
just suddenly,
I mean I still remember that because it
was this moment that really
crystallized,
you know,
the fact of being in a free country that
you can actually do this.
And I want to talk about some of the
issues of being in a free country,
but let's do,
let's do one other thing on first
because I mentioned some stuff about
Russia up top.
What do you make of just generally
what's happening with Russia now?
Just,
let's spend a couple minutes on that.
Putin is really trying to fill this void
that America seems to be leaving in the
world.
What,
what is going on in Syria?
Have they officially taken Ukraine?
GimMe Gimme state of
Russia on the state of Russia.
I thought,
uh,
you know,
pushing.
Definitely ever since he came to power,
it's been increasingly clear that I
think he wants to,
you know,
rebuild a Russia as a superpower.
It can really return to what the Soviet
Union was,
although I'm not really sure he
understands that he took Ukraine right
or.
Yeah,
well he is.
He took Crimea.
Yeah.
There is this view that puts in a sort
of super humanly claver right.
And,
you know,
he's this great strategist.
I'm not really sure that's the case
because,
you know,
actually,
uh,
arguably he could have gotten further
with Ukraine if he had just maintained
a,
you know,
tried to maintain a friendly
relationship with them then,
you know,
trade and so on without actually trying
to force his person.
I don't want to say his puppet because.
Yeah,
I don't,
I'm not even really sure that the
president who was a who was removed was
completely a puppet of the prevalent,
but he was definitely sort of Putin's
man and I think he in a way kind of
overplayed his hand.
Uh,
in Ukraine.
Um,
I mean right now he's in a situation
where he's much better at kind of
messing things up for other countries
than he is a,
you know,
actually doing something good for Russia
because right now for instance,
the situation with Ukraine is that,
yeah,
I mean the,
the new government in Ukraine is not
really able to push through the reforms
that are ones partly because it's bogged
down in this endless kind of undeclared
war that's going on in the eastern
regions.
And you know,
they've got poor breathing down their
neck basically.
But at the same time Russia is also
bogged down in this.
I'm declared war and it can really tell.
A lot of the stuff can kind of come back
and bite Russia because they're creating
this kind of quasi mercenary army of
armed people who will have the
experience now of fighting.
And the guerrilla war and who knows what
will happen when these people are told,
well we don't need you anymore because
we're kind of done with this.
So I think that's good.
Prayed a lot of the stabilization in
Russia itself.
Um,
and he and I could go on and on and
under does because he's also his god,
he's kind of got a tiger by the tail and
Chechnya because basically he made a
deal with a guy runs on Kadira of,
of well you basically like,
you make sure church now stays a Russian
province and you know,
you make sure that on God's 100 percent
of the votes and judge now elections,
which I think he does and you know,
you make sure that,
you know,
we get a cut of the oil profits and
exchange,
you can really do anything you want.
So,
and this is actually kind of interesting
because I know that there are people on
the rights in the west who see Putin as
this kind of bull work of the fence
against Sharia law,
uh,
under Putin's leadership there as a part
of the Russian Federation.
That is basically a Sharia state,
which has changed now.
Yeah.
And not many people know that this,
I didn't know that it actually is.
It's,
you know,
women are forced to wear veils,
this was a guy who was actually spoken
out in favor of a,
um,
a polygamy which is technically illegal
under a Russian law and,
you know,
and there are people who have said like,
wait a minute,
you know,
this guy is the president of a,
a,
you know,
a republic that is part of the Russian
Federation.
What is he doing?
Really advocating things that are
contrary to the Russian constitution.
And of course,
who really cares because,
you know,
the law currently is votes to keep the
boats.
And also this guy is a Cadeira is,
is a very,
very strong and supporter.
Like he,
uh,
if necessary he will bring out his
troops that are loyal to him,
you know,
to fight.
Uh,
I mean,
I,
it's pretty well known that he's sent
people to eastern Ukraine to,
uh,
to fight in the guerrilla war there.
So.
Yeah.
But at the same time,
it has kind of a tiger by the tail
situation because if suddenly it becomes
out of the stages for turn tournament,
you know,
who knows what's going to happen.
And he's a,
he's a pretty dangerous guy,
you know,
he's a,
he's kind of the classic warlord who
was,
you know,
God as people who are extremely loyal,
they have a potential,
is quite as smart as his often given
credit for it.
I think a lot of the time when he's
succeeded,
it's mainly because of the failures of
the West because,
you know,
he has his side.
He is,
he's good at stepping into the vacuum
that arises when,
for instance,
in American leadership kind of pulls
back.
So that's the perfect segue of course,
to everything that's going on in Syria.
What is he trying to accomplish in
Syria?
Is He really trying to.
And I think part of that is really just
to signal that,
you know,
he stands behind US allies.
Uh,
and yeah,
he's a sensibly making noises about,
you know,
creating the preconditions for a,
a sod to talk to,
talk to the opposition.
But,
you know,
given the way that put him treats the
opposition and Russia,
I mean,
okay,
he doesn't carpet bomb,
but uh,
uh,
but that's really,
other than that,
the rest of it,
he's really not a talking to the
opposition guy.
He's more of a,
you know,
kill the opposition quietly or,
put them in jail or,
you know,
basically leave them with no
institutional support whatsoever guy.
And,
you know,
we,
I,
I think it's really fairly clear that,
you know,
the,
the murder of Boris Nemtsov who was a
forum at one point,
a really popular governor who later
became part of the opposition.
And uh,
um,
you know,
who I think,
who had the charisma really to,
uh,
to appeal to people.
I don't know that he actually was
directly a threat to put in.
But,
you know,
buddy might sell it.
It's fairly clear that there was some
kind of official hand in his murder.
So,
I mean,
I think that kind of tells you a lot
about,
um,
you know,
how puts in feels about dealing with the
possession.
So basically the idea here,
I think he wants to keep us on empower.
I think my guy,
it's probably good for the economy at
some level.
Yeah,
exactly.
And I think it's good for kind of
maintaining strong man image both inside
and outside Russia put there.
I clearly kind of has an affinity with
dictators a,
he gets pretty upset at regime change
anywhere,
you know,
he was from,
I've heard stories and I got and you
know,
these are sort of rumors from people who
are,
who have been on the inside,
but I've heard that he was extremely
upset by what happened to Qaddafi and
that he really took that personally.
He took it personally.
Yeah.
Well that's what they may someday way.
And I think he,
part of his issues with the United
States and I think it goes back to a
rock and a few other things.
But he really does see the United States
as,
you know,
promoting regime change around the
world.
And um,
and I think that's part of this beef
with the US.
Yeah.
So,
so is that the irony of where we're at
at the moment that it seems to me that
the Democrats and Hillary are more anti
Russia than the Republicans at the
moment.
Now maybe trump has business ties for
going in and toppling Gaddafi and
apparently now it came out that a lot of
the leaders of the army were saying
don't do it.
So.
So there is some legitimacy to Putin's
fears,
I suppose,
if you were putting.
You can.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean I think that,
uh,
what,
when we'll look at it and I don't really
want to get until the whole Middle East.
We're going,
we're going to spend the next hour
talking about the Middle East.
Yeah,
I understand the kind of anti
introduction of good men.
I think we've definitely overextended
ourselves and you know,
doing things around the world that get
us into really messy situations.
At the same time,
I'm a little skeptical of this whole
kind of line of argument that,
oh,
well we've made such a mess.
There was this assumption that if only
it weren't for our intervention,
like everything would be,
you know,
peaceful and quiet.
I think that that's necessarily the case
and I think that in a way,
it's funny because it kind of parallels
a lot of the left wing arguments about
foreign policy.
Like the other day I saw somebody on
twitter and I don't,
I'm not even sure why this came up,
but for some reason they were talking
about how,
oh,
well it was really Nixon who was
responsible for the genocide in
Cambodia.
I don't know what he was actually
responsible for that.
So it's this mindset that somehow the
west is behind everything bad that
happens in non western countries.
And I think it's again,
kind of ironic that we're seeing the
same kind of mindset on the,
on the anti interventionist,
right.
Today.
And again,
this is not to say that,
you know,
mistakes have been made so to speak,
but it really doesn't mean that,
you know,
if we,
if we hadn't blundered in Libya and Iraq
and so on,
that,
that region today would be just,
you know,
what model of peace and quiet I don't
think that we have no idea by the way
what would have happened.
But we do know that actually Iraq was
better and they were having basically
free elections and then we left,
had signed the thing to leave.
But Obama is a collective responsibility
for this.
I think,
um,
you know,
uh,
leaving aside the merits of the invasion
itself,
I think it's pretty clear that the
administration and Iraq post invasion
was very badly mismanaged.
Dan,
I think that was part of why I think
they weren't able to get a deal that
would have allowed us to keep some
troops there.
Um,
but again,
we don't want them to all think what
you're saying is that not everything all
the time,
no,
it's not.
And that it's really whether you're
blaming George W dot Bush or whether
you're a blaming Hillary.
And Obama,
you know,
it's really much,
much more complicated than that.
There are forces,
and it's kind of ironic because in a
way,
in a ways demeaning really to the people
in those countries to say that,
oh,
well,
everything they do is really only
because of instigation and so forth.
They have their own extremely
complicated history.
Um,
and you know,
they do things for their own reasons.
I mean,
obviously we're contribute for better or
for worse,
but it's,
it's really an oversimplification to say
that,
oh well.
And a lot of conservatives are saying
that now.
Oh,
well,
Hillary started this mess in the Middle
East
also.
Of course,
it always depends on where you want to
start history,
because there was something called the
Ottoman Empire,
that realm,
and then there was the British empire
and then the United States and all that.
Okay.
So,
yeah,
so.
All right,
let's,
uh,
let's move from some geo political stuff
and let's talk about the issues of the
day.
Let's,
let's come back to America for a moment
because that's where you do most of your
writing about now.
And
no know I do actually write quite a bit
about Russia because I do have,
you know,
the,
the experience that I think,
you know,
it was really helpful in assessing
what's happening there.
Yeah.
So.
All right,
let's start with,
we're going to talk about the regressive
left and the alt right.
Which one would you prefer to start
with?
What feels like a better transition
there?
Uh,
you mean like what I like to start?
Well,
there were regressive laughter.
All right first.
Oh,
let's do the alt right.
Okay.
So let's do
Italy in Russia is a good kind of segue
to the alt right because I think that a
lot of people on the outright have the
uh,
you know,
put some cold.
Yeah.
Okay.
So how would you just give me your.
And of course a lot of them are just
crumbling walls.
Really.
There's a lot of trolls on the.
Alright,
we know that.
But what is,
what is your definition of the alt
right?
What is the outright to you?
Because I think nobody's defining it
properly.
So everyone,
everyone uses it for their own right.
But they're on purpose
right?
Well,
it's difficult to define actually
because,
uh,
there probably isn't a single.
All right.
Um,
I mean it started maybe five or six
years ago,
uh,
was a bunch of people on really obscure
websites and there are these different
kind of factions of the outright,
some of which are the,
like there's the end.
I haven't really written about the whole
neoreaction array,
so called dub phenomenon,
which is really about a kind of going
back to pre democracy political
institutions,
you know,
a lot of them are three pro monitor
care,
which is kind of a nonstarter.
The United States.
It's not,
let's not tear up the whole system.
That was.
Yeah.
But I think today what people,
uh,
with people we usually have referred to
when they talk about the alt right is
it's more kind of white nationalist
segments.
And I think that has primarily come to
be,
uh,
associated especially with the,
um,
the trump campaign,
which,
uh,
you know,
the alt right has been kind of a,
a,
an affiliate.
Okay.
Way.
So,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but my.
My take on it has been that when people
refer to the alt right,
yeah,
they're referring to this white
nationalist group of people and these
neonazis in that thing.
My feeling about it from what I've seen,
just being online and talking to people
and seeing what people send me things is
that a huge percentage of the alt right
is just really disaffected.
People who love memes and they love shit
posting and sending a Nazi imagery to
people and all this stuff.
Not because they're Nazis,
but they're so frustrated with the
system that they're just trying to get a
reaction.
Now I'm not apologizing for them and I
don't like getting those things.
I wouldn't stop them.
Sure we get as long as they're not
trying to physically harm anybody,
but I.
to me,
the the white nationalist subset of it
obviously exists,
but it actually strikes me as a small
portion of a movement that really is
just pissed it conservatives that are
pissed at the people on the right who
didn't do the things they said they were
going to do.
They're pissed at the system,
they're pissed at the media.
I mean,
a lot of the things that I actually do
care about yet,
there is absolutely a truly Zena phobic
component to it that doesn't like black
people,
that doesn't like Muslims,
gays,
Jews,
et cetera.
Do you think that's fair to say that
there's some,
it's really difficult to estimate the
percentages because it's not like it's
not a movement where you can do a poll
and find out what percentage of people
who are sort of affiliated with the alt
right online,
uh,
or actually just sort of disaffected
conservatives or libertarians who,
you know,
like names and shit posting or former
liberal liberal.
Yeah.
As opposed to,
you know,
actual white nationalists or uh,
even neo Nazis,
uh,
we don't have a know how many people are
actually involved because a lot of them
could be like,
one person was the 30 handles.
It could be like a,
what was that guy's name?
Joshua Goldberg.
Remember this was the,
a Jewish guy who had all these different
identities including,
uh,
including a Nazi.
He posted.
Oh yeah.
This is an amazing story.
And I actually,
he eventually got a rust,
the current season of south park,
I don't know if you're watching,
but I know I know.
No,
but he eventually got arrested I think
for a raw trying to stage some kind of a
terrorist attack.
Like he was talking to some radical
Muslims online also and I think he was
trying to persuade them that he was a
radical Muslim too.
And so he was trolling every one,
but he had some personas that really
were,
you know,
that we're all right.
And so yeah,
we could be,
you know,
dealing with you don't know,
you never really know who we are dealing
with,
you know,
you can be dealing with a teenager who
know,
sitting in his parents bail basement,
you know,
and pretending to be like 10 or 15
different people on twitter.
So then what do you make of the,
of the strength of it then Hillary,
when Hillary calls out the alt right,
are we talking about an actual political
movement here or
is something of a political movement?
I mean,
we know that there are these,
there are people,
um,
websites like vade there,
you know,
those are real people,
those are not,
you know,
teenagers a pretending to be somebody
well,
posting from their parents' basement.
Uh,
now how much do they actually have?
Again,
nobody knows.
But I do think that there's a real
movement there.
I think that they are gaining a lot of
visibility recently and it's really
difficult to even know how to deal with
those because in a way of course,
by criticizing them,
you know,
people like me aren't giving them more
visibility,
but at the same time I do kind of feel
that it is important to.
And I really hate the word call out
because it's been so thoroughly kind of,
you know,
appropriate.
Uh,
Duh,
you know,
Ms Dot Hughes by the social justice
people.
But I do think that it's important to
point to this and say,
yeah,
you know,
this was really going on in.
This was not a good thing.
And I think that,
um,
there are young people who do kind of
ton to get drawn in by the stuff.
For Real,
we have a lot of young people,
uh,
who are extremely uneducated,
you know,
and I think that is a problem with the
educational system.
We have a problem of kind of teaching
relativism and the Sun's Thought,
oh,
well,
you know,
there's really no such thing as
objective truth and I think people have,
people have been saying for a long time,
you know,
those kinds of mindset eventually leads
to embracing Holocaust denial that says,
hey,
you know,
who's to say what really happened of the
real truth is really historical truth is
really only just a matter of who gets to
control the narrative,
you know?
Right.
That is a big problem because whoever
yells,
I mean,
just yesterday,
did you see this guy at the trump
rallies screaming about it?
It's like,
I didn't retweet it because I don't want
to amplify these crazy people.
And yet at the same point they've
suddenly found a voice,
trump.
And I don't,
I don't think he's obviously,
I don't think he's a Holocaust denier,
but there you.
What is the connection to trump in this?
I guess it's,
the
connection to trump is not because of
his rhetoric on immigration and not,
not his specific positions so much as
just that kind of level of vehemence and
the common flake,
you know,
and I'm in the,
yeah,
it's true that he didn't say all Mexican
illegal immigrants are rapists,
but like the whole,
Oh,
you know,
these Mexican,
Mexico is something as these rapists,
uh,
you know,
kind of stuff.
I think it did Sunday message to a lot
of people on the kind of genuine,
lazy,
no fallback.
Um,
uh,
you know,
parts of the outright that,
hey,
you know,
this is a guy who thinks that way we do.
And um,
I think ann coulter is kind of a conduit
there too because she's,
you know,
she's actually engaged for years in some
extremely,
um,
uh,
kind of a nasty rhetoric targeting all
sorts of different people and including
immigrants and invitation to come on the
show by the way.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
And you know,
she became a big cheerleader for trump.
And I mean,
the,
the story that I've heard is that
actually it's the success of her
anti-immigration book,
you know,
audio Adios America,
uh,
was what,
what kind of drove trump to decide
suddenly to make an aggression,
uh,
the biggest show of his campaign because
he never really.
This is kind of the interesting thing.
In 2012,
he actually criticized Mitt Romney for
being too anti integration,
which is funny in a way when people talk
about trump,
you know,
being this and that.
Ideologically,
I think trump ideological,
he trump is a trump.
See,
you know,
he's a,
is interested in his own advancement.
And that's it.
That doesn't make him not dangerous
because you know,
and an ego maniac who is a,
you know,
very close to being president of.
Well,
I don't know how close right now,
if either one of them went to the trump
points.
I agree.
I think he's,
he's out for his own.
We don't know it.
I don't think we fully understand what
his motivations are,
which may be all presidents have that.
But what I think Hillary is the more
conventional,
egomaniac political.
My fear with the trump thing is that
it's not,
I don't think he's a white nationalist
or something like that by any
estimation,
but I think he's allowed for it to
suddenly become.
It's sort of okay,
you know,
and I like you.
I'm a free speech absolutist.
So as long as these people aren't
calling to harm for letting them be out
there and I'm not for banning any of
them,
just like I'm not for banning Milo from
twitter and all that,
but I fear at some level that we're
normalizing.
Well that's,
yeah,
I think that is a problem and I think
that is really why I felt that it was
important to,
uh,
to address this and I have.
And I really do have.
I mean,
I think Milo was a very smart guy who
has done some great things and you know,
criticizing and mocking the social
justice warriors.
I mean,
I think it was a really,
really big mistake for him to start
essentially normalizing and legitimizing
the,
uh,
these kind of creepy or uh,
segments of the outright,
right?
Yeah.
Already.
Have you seen them turn on him lately?
Because I've seen Nazis show up.
And how much of that is theater,
you know,
I mean,
I don't know how many of these people
like,
yeah,
I never actually get out of the
basement.
Uh,
I would imagine so.
Yeah,
time.
It's probably.
Yeah.
Um,
so yeah,
I think a lot of what goes on while the
outright as theater.
I mean,
you know,
I've gotten threatening tweets and
messages from these people that I don't
really take seriously.
I mean,
it's a,
I think a lot of that as really just
kind of showing off and kind of being
assholes on twitter.
Uh,
so the same time,
you know,
when,
when you have a lot of this very violent
rhetoric going on,
you never know when it's going to
actually,
uh,
you know,
trickled down to the wrong person who
actually decides to do something about
it and not just some tweets and so on.
So I'm not going to say that this is
sort of not dangerous because when you
have a lot of this rhetoric that
demonizes people that calls for
violence,
uh,
I mean there's a lot of rhetoric come
calling for,
you know,
retaliation against enemies of trump.
And I've seen a lot of,
you know,
I,
I think that the,
the,
the rhetorical atmosphere,
the rhetorical climate right now is
really,
is really bad.
And of course I'm not going to blame
that entirely on the.
All right,
this may be a good moment.
So that's a segue to the regressive.
That's exactly where I wanted to go with
that because my,
the reason I've been somewhat
sympathetic to whatever the alt right
is,
is that I do see,
and I'm not defending the white
nationalists and for the purpose of
this,
but for all of the people that are just
shit posting and upsetting everybody and
are and are sending memes all over the
place and trying to be heard and all
that.
They're angry at the establishment,
which I fully understand and they're
angry at political correctness and who
did that.
To them it was the regressive left,
it was the people on the left that
silenced everybody with these false
cries of racism and they're a natural
reaction.
And that's why I've been sort of what
Hollywood kind of chaotic reaction,
real argument that I remember actually
arguing with my low back.
The 40 abroad does articles that were
kind of serious way when he was just
kind of starting to kind of dabble and
you know,
apologize for the alt right.
And he was basically saying,
oh,
well,
you see what,
what's really going on here as that they
want to challenge these taboos say
because a bit.
Because the racist label is constantly
being used.
The silence conservatives,
uh,
they're actually trying to kind of make
that stigma,
meaning meaningless by actually saying
that doesn't really work that way first
of all bought.
But by doing this,
um,
because I do think that the vast
majority of people who are not social
justice warriors,
who are not the regressive left a
nonetheless quite rightly low the and,
you know,
detest genuine racism and bigotry.
Uh,
what you're doing by saying all this
crap is alienating people who could be,
it could be,
it could be your allies because you know
that they're gonna look at you and say,
Oh,
well,
you know,
these people really are racist crepes.
No,
thank you.
We don't really want anything to do with
them.
Say,
you know,
I mean,
that's really a little bit like a,
you know,
like if you're a black person who wants
to challenge negative stereotypes of
blocks,
you're not gonna do that by,
you know,
trying to embody the bed.
Like,
oh,
the,
I suppose the,
you have some people in the yellow,
the rap community who kind of do that
and that stupid,
you know,
and it's,
it's stupid when,
uh,
when anti pc people do it,
it's a,
you know,
but,
but I totally agree that the,
the left bears a lot of responsibility
for the climate of uh,
you know,
the,
the really,
really bad,
um,
and counterproductive rhetorical climate
that we have a uncouple some of that
from left because that's,
you know,
that's why I've spent so much time
talking about this show is that I want
liberalism to turn to logic and reason
and not always demonizing everybody.
How do I do that?
And he said almost too late because we
now see whether side gaining power and
that much more scared of the people that
are stuck.
Right.
Well,
I don't think it's too late.
I mean,
I don't think we're at the point yet.
You know,
we're not in the Soviet Union were not
at the point where you can go to prison
for,
you know,
wrong thing.
But you do see the findings of that.
But we do see the underpinnings of that.
I think it's really important for,
uh,
you know,
genuine liberals.
What I would love to see by the way is a
kind of liberal conservative alliance of
reasonable people.
And I think right now that is feasible.
I think we're seeing a lot of that.
We're seeing people like,
you know,
Jonathan chait on the liberal side of,
for instance,
speaking out against political
correctness and getting attacked by the
regressive love.
And as a,
you know,
the attacks are really always the same.
You know,
it's kind of,
oh,
like you're just another white male who
doesn't like women and minorities
criticizing you and you know,
and the only thing worse than a white
male who doesn't think the way he spoke
was because actually if you look at the
article that Jonathan Shade got a talk,
he was talking about criticism directed
at himself.
He was actually talking mainly about
women in minorities who were getting a
toxin really nasty ways for being
politically incorrect.
Um,
he was talking about people like this
Muslim student at the University of
Michigan who got really badly harassed
for,
you know,
writing something that mark political
correctness.
I mean,
I think he had like a bunch of really
nasty leaflets dropped in front of the
door of his apartment and stuff like
that.
So,
I mean,
it wasn't even just people tweeting
nasty things and so on.
It was a really,
in a way kind of quotes I physical
harassment.
Uh,
so yeah,
I think that there is a um,
uh,
there was a movement of both
conservatives and liberals who are very,
very ready to reject this and to kind of
try to restore rationality.
What I would love to see,
by the way,
and this is kind of my,
my own personal dream right now,
there isn't a single publication like I
read a lot of publications online.
I don't think there was a single
publication that could have consistently
stands up for a non sort of social
justice.
And I put this,
the word social justice in quotation
marks because,
because,
you know,
it really is a kind of what passes for
social justice today is neil to tell
attarian cult really is obsessed with
controlling words and thoughts.
It's obsessed with identity politics and
it's obsessed with politicizing every
single aspect of life.
It's like when you look at,
for instance,
the discussions of culture like movie,
whether it's movies,
video games,
uh,
books,
everything in the progressive media
like,
you know,
vice,
a bridge to some extent of in the daily
beast,
which I've written for in,
which I think does,
I mean the daily beast is one of the few
that doesn't kind of completely cooptive
by this and still publishes,
you know,
good stuff.
But,
um,
he or you know,
stuff that doesn't fit that kind of
identity politics mode.
But a lot of that,
like all of the discussion of
television,
everything,
it's completely in terms of,
you know,
oh,
well does this really rough luck,
you know,
the,
the true diversity of the population.
And,
you know,
do we have enough trans people and this.
And this is this cultural appropriation.
You know,
where does this writer really have the
right to talk about this ethnic group
the way that he or she does and it's all
in terms of this ideology and identity
and it's ridiculous.
So that,
and I think what we,
what I would love to see.
So there's that and there's the
conservative media on the other hand up,
but there isn't a single publication
that could have consistently embraces a,
you know,
kind of true liberal point of view.
I mean there are still some publications
are likely Atlantic,
the daily based that have that point of
view represented,
but it coexists with a lot of the really
hardcore kind of ideological,
uh,
Neela to talent tell Ryan as I would
call it.
And I think what that coexistence very
often tends to lead to the liberal
viewpoint being pushed out because the,
the social justice people,
they're really not interested in
dialogue.
They think that the opposing viewpoint
as evil.
Yeah.
So I mean it's a little bit like a,
you know,
you can't really have a dialogue between
voltaire on Torquemada was volunteering
thing burned at the stake.
And so I think trend what we really need
and I would love to see this,
you know,
like the,
like the old new or a public for
instance.
I mean the new new republic,
it is this,
you know,
lamentable,
shadow of its former self were avoided
that,
I don't know if you saw the other day
there,
they had this really bizarre essay
called what are white writers for or
something.
And Yeah.
And it contained this line,
which I actually screenshot it on
twitter that said something like,
well for the most part white people have
always been able to do everything they
want to do.
It is detached from reality.
I mean really seriously.
And it's like these people don't even
realize how profoundly elitist because
it's like they think.
And the guy who wrote this as a Yale
Grad,
you know,
so you think that your experience as a
writer who went to Yale,
it because your wife is identical to the
experience of some white guy who lives
in Kentucky and as good of a job.
But it was going to vote for trump by
the way,
because you people keep telling him
that,
you know,
he is a racist because he is not happy
with where he is in life and he knows
that,
you know,
what I think we really,
really need more voices for this kind of
liberalism that doesn't,
you know,
both moderate conservatism,
which I think has been,
you know,
largely edge down these days.
But,
you know,
the rush limbaughs.
And so I think,
I mean,
national review I think still has some
really good kind of a national review
commentary.
Um,
you know,
those,
those publications have some really good
kind of traditional conservative voices.
But I think we're really,
really need more of that and we're
needed more liberal,
a liberal will publications,
uh,
that consistently advanced
a liberal law point of view.
You know,
I really liked what you said about this,
this new thing for me because I've been
sort of talking about a little bit and
I've had a few guests that have
mentioned it and I've been saying for
awhile that it seems to me that
defending my liberal values is now
becoming a conservative position.
That doesn't make me feel good to say
that.
But,
but I think that shows that there's a
bridge to be built here.
I want to back up to something else that
you said,
which is that everything's being
politicized these days.
Because yesterday I saw on twitter
somebody tweeted that the,
the lead actress in the show,
blackish,
uh,
which has doubled the ratings I suppose.
I guess,
of,
of Tim Allen's newer show.
Not home improvement.
The one that's on now.
And it said that he makes something like
20 times more than him and what the
implication was with somehow that he as
a white man is making more than this
black woman.
And I think that line in general is just
a misguided way of attacking.
But it was really.
They were trying to solve some sort of
social injustice,
but really Tim Allen is a massive star
who I think,
if I'm not mistaken,
it's been around for name.
He's the only person ever to have a
number one movie number one book and
number one second of all at the same.
We're all the same week.
So this is a massive star who's reaping
the benefits of being the headline guy
in a sycamore.
Oprah Winfrey,
I'm sure,
makes a lot more money than you do.
Believe it or not exactly.
Sure how the Youtube CPM work out.
But yes she does.
And I'm a white guy.
Ah,
what does that prove?
There you go.
But,
but that idea that everything is
politicized,
it's,
it's really dangerous,
right?
As someone that comes from absolute,
everything was political.
Absolutely.
And,
and,
and it's,
it's really,
really discouraging to me to see,
especially a lot of the cultural
criticism,
a couch completely in these political
terms.
Uh,
it's like,
you know,
you can read a random review of some TV
show and suddenly you see a lot in a
long the lines of,
well,
of course,
you know,
in,
in the rape culture of,
you know,
modern American society,
men,
women are systematically suppressed,
you know,
cannot express their wishes freely.
And so,
you know,
and it's like,
it reminds me of how when I was growing
up in the Soviet Union,
you know,
going back to that experience,
I had these additions of classics like
Shakespeare in translation and there was
a kind of obligatory thing where
virtually any publication of,
um,
of a classic had to have a forward that
had to have at least some passages that
put it in the proper kind of Marxist
context.
A warning before trigger will trigger
warning so much as kind of an
ideological framework that told you,
you know,
what the correct weight are we.
That was.
So for instance,
you know,
Shakespeare's King Lear is really about
the emergence of the bourgeoisie and its
replacement.
Uh,
you know,
the feudal family system.
So on and uh,
and it really has,
and there would be a quote from either
mark's or London and it was funny
because apparently in the Russian
publishing industry I've heard people
actually used to refer to these Marx and
Lenin quotes as locomotives because they
were like pulling the,
throw the publication of the book,
you know,
and you couldn't get the book published
otherwise.
So,
and it's not necessarily the person who
wrote the foreword believed any of that.
I will just this obligatory nod to the
reigning ideology and I think we're
almost getting to the point where you
look at a lot of TV movie book reviews
in a,
you know,
kind of progressive left of center
publications and it's the same kind of
stuff,
you know,
you see these,
references to the race,
gender,
you know,
sexuality,
identity,
politics,
ideology,
a that permeates everything.
And uh,
and it's scary,
especially in terms of gender and gender
issues and relations between men and
women.
Uh,
we haven't even gotten to the thought,
you know,
I've been doing a lot of writing on
gender.
Unfortunately.
We're out of time.
So you absolutely are going to come
back,
whether you like it or not,
I'm not forcing you to come back,
do time next time we're going to do a
full hour of gender issues,
do all the gender is feminism and men
rights and all that.
But I,
I really do love how you brought this
back to where we started because the
themes of being in a society that are
closed,
we're in an open one now and someone
like you that's lived through the other
side can,
can see some of the frameworks of it
happening here.
So that's why I'm glad that we brought
her in.
So I'll give you the last word.
Well,
I mean,
I think he,
the,
he made a really good point about how we
have an open society that as suddenly
somehow reproducing a lot of these
thought patterns of closed society is a
society is where there is a dominant
ideology.
And I think that is something that we
all have to be very,
very leery of.
Um,
I think,
you know,
the saying the world exclusively through
a political slash ideological lens,
uh,
is a really,
really limited and skewed way of looking
at the world and it also really keeps
you from looking at the opposing point
of view because,
you know,
if,
if a point of view that is different
from yours is not just a different point
of view,
but the enemy,
uh,
you know,
that is really not a,
no,
that is really not very conducive to
getting a full picture of what's going
on in the world.
And I think that applies by the way,
again,
to a lot of people on the right as well
as people in the love.
I think that,
you know,
the right kind of has its own version of
political,
correct.
No,
I'm not defending the right.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
I think we,
uh,
yeah,
and I'm gonna repeat it again.
I think we need to add my own politics.
Quite a moderate libertarian really.
I'm not extremely doctrinaire about,
you know,
minimal government.
I mean,
I obviously think less government is
better,
but you know,
I'm probably not quite as a minimalistic
about government or some of my
colleagues that reason.
Sure.
Uh,
I mean,
I think that there are legitimate
disagreements that we can have about,
you know,
the size of government,
about welfare programs.
These are all legitimate subject for
discussion.
Uh,
as long as you know,
you,
you understand that your point of view
could be wrong,
you know,
that you're not necessarily write about
everything.
And you know,
unfortunately the identity politics are
a whole different ballgame because
unlike the debates about the nature of
the welfare state,
for instance,
identity politics,
uh,
does turn to put people in boxes.
Identity politics tends to demonize the
opposition.
And,
uh,
the,
the social justice ideology,
uh,
that,
a really kind of seeks to control how
people even talk about identity and
related issues.
And that's a whole difference.
And that's a whole different story.
And this is where,
you know,
I,
I don't think it's really possible to
conduct a dialogue with people who
espouse to Terry and ideology.
I'm going to keep trying.
And you absolutely,
you're coming back where we're going to
get interested in as I last,
I like to say on a good interview.
I don't even look at these ones.
I didn't pick them up once,
so it was a pleasure.
Thanks for coming.
Thanks for coming to La and doing this
and finally meet you and I really want
to do this again.
We're actually,
we're real people in more than 140
characters.
I can't believe it.
For more on Kathy,
you can check out cathy young dot word
press.com.
Thanks for watching.